[Music]
does anyone feel as strongly as I do
when it comes to preserving cultures and
languages it's not only ironic coming
out of my mouth because my son doesn't
speak Spanish and I tried teaching him
there came out of my mouth that I would
not teach you Cantonese because I think
it's a dying language what an optimist I
am really sad cuz I don't know like when
I hear about the whole Japanese
internment camps like period in the US
and how a lot of Japanese people wanted
to erase their culture and just to
simulate to the American culture that
like breaks my heart hearing that well
they wanted to do that outwardly though
not necessarily in with me
well like a lot of that was mostly them
trying to seem like they were trying to
acclimate to u.s. culture but but then
eventually it ended up happening anyway
but but but they didn't necessarily want
to do that they were just trying to do
with the fight ya know yeah everyone
wanted them you know not necessarily
that they wanted to yeah yeah but yeah
trying to prove the patriotism exactly
my grandma my grandparents really were
Patriots though they like they came over
here through the u.s. Navy from the
Philippines yeah and they were so happy
to be Americans that they didn't want to
teach their kids to college or anything
cuz they wanted them to like assimilate
and like blend in and like the American
and they were just thankful to like you
come citizens
so it's interesting hearing two sides of
the coin - because I'm bummed I want to
know Tagalog and my dad wishes he knew
Tagalog but for them they were like we
succeeded in being Americans
so it's interesting that's true my
great-great-great parents were slave
owners and they were like listen we
really want to teach this places no they
wanted to teach the slaves mad they
wanted teachers place math which a lot
of slave owners at the time they're like
we don't think that that's a good idea
much progresses yeah right and then you
know actually my great-great-great
grandparents they taught their slaves
math which i think is pretty cool that's
nice yeah so then make it count the
amount of years that they were slaves
for thanks were they grateful for it did
they like know their books are grateful
fun so believable
no if you have slave owners so I'm great
and your family trees you gave them that
knowledge yeah and then you're loud and
ultimately they live an uprising and
they use it against them look we added
up we've been they backstabbing like
this for two generations and that's
[ __ ] up and then my grandma's like god
dammit I told you Harold and then Harold
Harold true story
hundred percent really yeah well anyway
I am pretty bummed that I did not
succeed in passing on the language of
Spanish to my son it's not too late Bob
has a good foundation you can pick it up
in high school or whatever teenage brain
though you distracted it's cause like
okay a lot of people tell me like what
well what do you mean like you could
easily just speak to him Spanish all day
he'll pick it up and water it's not easy
teaching someone that rejects the the
thing that you're trying to teach I have
to want it you know I've been kind of
fight incepting this thought of like
it's really really badass and cool to
know different languages we started
watching we started watching James Bond
and I was like oh geez what's being
Spanish in this scene fast hi how many
like that whole thing about switching
the language on on whatever he's
watching when he was younger when he was
like like two years old three years old
I would switch all the Disney DVDs to be
in Spanish so I tried guys I did I would
but then instead he would be so angry
that he'd leave the room she hated it
when I was on Spanish and I'm like what
what are you what do you understood I
gave it got his mom's y'all that I'm
again intelligent
do you sound like they're yelling huh
when they're in Spanish they were like
more high-pitched it's hard though when
you have a primary language mother who's
primarily English like not friends
really it's just hard that's hard
especially like you know with Casey not
knowing Spanish - it's been really hard
to implement that's all you're ruined
it's really not a failure though it's my
I feel like a failure so angle you know
why because that was hella judgmental
when I was a younger and then there
would be kids in my school and almost
everyone spoke Spanish but then this kid
like they'd be like oh yeah I'm Mexican
I speak Spanish I was such dude old
Mexican ladies get mad at me for not
knowing Spanish because they think I'm
Mexican
yeah and then like say it back to hola
and they're like ah see he knows I don't
know sometimes I'm like maybe that was
my car line you know I judge for being a
[ __ ] already like what 2nd generation
yeah so the other kid is probably like
Isaac's generation and his family know
that's why I'm saying I'm like the news
car my should have been more
understanding and just be like hey you
know what what if you want to learn
I could teach you're also a kid Hey look
I go to my van huh and I'm like 8 DP
and they're like oh I'm so good at
Spanish Mexican restaurant see Steve's
like shoulders like I need to leave now
I need to leave don't get
how you say c'mon cds say chimichanga
thank you
gracias oh my god swing thank you
anyway the reason why I bring up
language is because this guy named
Daniel he has created an online library
to preserve all the languages so there's
there's 7,000 languages that are spoken
around the world and 500 of them are at
risk of being forgotten does he know
that this is already covered I mean
there's there's literally a place in
Antarctica that has the entire [ __ ]
human dictionary and it has like every
species is that the plants in it
overseas exactly exactly why is it in
Antarctica why is it why is the key to
human history in the place where humans
don't go no one could steal it preserves
it's Noah's Ark bro it's got our entire
history baked into it so yeah that's
good Oliver put some more plants in
there I'm like cool okay probably
probably is but we also spent Voyager 1
and Voyager 2 in space and that has like
all that [ __ ] interesting well I'm gonna
play a little video clip inside on earth
about 500 of them are currently at risk
of disappearing as the number of native
speakers dwindles my name is Daniel and
I'm the co-founder and director of wiki
tones a non-profit powered by more than
a thousand volunteers around the world
working the preserve mode and pass on
every language to the next generation
every day hundreds of volunteers around
the world are recording videos just
Ettie sama is pune yahwah ecologica aloo
chiyogami i help keep track of all of
these videos since they're submitted so
that they can be reused for educational
and cultural purposes wiki tongues has
recorded over 435 languages from over 70
countries that number changes every day
there are plenty examples of languages
being brought back from the dead there's
Cornish there's paper there's Tunica
it's a way of ensuring that future
generations can revive their languages
even if they go extinct well cool can
you guys you gen-y [ __ ] please like
because I just heard a kid tell me oh
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] it was I
don't know you're looking at me that
would you know it's Jordan no what was
it it was uh it's lit one of them one oh
we all know live hello it's not even in
no that's old [ __ ] it was two things put
together that made me go like wow you
could put those together like take the
Tuck no not quite not quite damn it
it was like it was like the end of a
sentence it's like it's so done that's
extra oh I got it ready periodic what
the [ __ ] that's all this [ __ ] Oh periods
here yacht it's like hey it's so done
it's got the it's got a D and then it's
got a t cuz it's so dumb so these
savings are - is it written what what
you where were you I was writing a
goddamn script and trying to have kids
talk like how kids talk and so be in
mind we're looking
out loud I would love you and I go like
shut the [ __ ] like it steve buscemi
you like outfitted like hello fellow you
fellow Jen wires in the [ __ ] like I'm
30 years I just heated my way over
but you guys remind me now of like 10
years ago when Michael had a co-writer
on smiley or yet it and and smiley what
yeah he he was older he was like 40 or
whatever he was 40 pen he was writing
dialogue for teenagers and it was
clearly like a 40-something person
writing dialogue for teenagers and you
guys are all making fun of it and now
you're that listen because the yesterday
when we were looking this [ __ ] up the
entire time Michael stay in the show a
lot I'm like you're [ __ ] boomer shut
the [ __ ] up studying them I'm beside you
them okay
okay boo boo Marie here a script advisor
of my new one thing can you imagine a
have even advised them they're like
those like 15 year old it's coming no no
no I'm just no we got every right that's
the problem is my main characters a 13
year old so then look you've been our
youngest people that we used to go to to
see like what was cool they're all like
23 now it's like too old now and they
were the 13 year old let's go always
always let's go why oh it's so like when
he's happy about something so you'd be
like mommy can have some talkies and I'm
like okay fine you had lunch he goes
let's go and I'm like well kind of say
that something literally beautiful no
cuz Tom Brady when he goes to field he's
like let's [ __ ] go so like
distinction and Tom Brady is like 43
yeah I think let's go has been around
for a while
the way that he's saying it with
gives me hope is on things that I could
I didn't understand to communicate that
it's like I'm it's like I went back into
ancient Egypt and I'm talking about like
oh yeah I don't speak your language I
wonder what that would be like to go
back inside and speak to someone in
English but it's not really English
because they have a different English
yeah yeah they probably burn you for
being a witch yeah by the way they're
probably like hey life sucks there's no
joy here [ __ ] off with you feel about
love island learning new words cuz
they're always like saying they have
different slang than us and so I'm
buzzing buzzing me and they'll be like
bug written on the forehead and I've
gotten across my face yeah I would love
it if like somebody wrote a fake British
show and didn't tell America that was a
bad shy I just like started coming up
with like [ __ ] did you cast young
enough kids though then all eat then all
these like people like me and Nick
you're like okay I guess kids were
saying mug now again that's what I mean
though it's like just do it and release
it on the world and see what happens
[Music]